our interior designer that was working
on our house the way she speaks what do
you mean just get a custom couch I get a
custom living a coffee table you get
everything built what do you mean what
is it made out of whatever you want
fiberglass you can have a clear couch if
you want man you can do that Restoration
Hardware you just look at it couch and
then you go I want that button leather
no restoration hard work to her is
Payless to her it's like why would you
buy that from a store when I can make a
shape that doesn't even exist and you're
the only one that has it yeah and I'm
like how much is that she's like 200
000. oh um I think we miscommunicated on
the budget to me I'm like Restoration
Hardware is like like that's the ceiling
for her that's like
[Laughter]